今日もん静岡の街番取っても平和って
でもある男か
とってもないことを考えていました
[音楽]
ame
me
[音楽]
いやーいい天気だなぁいいわけで私はその説は今とある駐車場の屋上でいいます
車は全然止まってないの
かなり素数かな状態なんですけれども今回はまたしょうもない曲を考えてしまいました
8合計まくるまでこの駐車場の屋上まで来たんですけどもう車まとめているんですけど
も
今たらこのような二日間が3日ほどここで放置します
放置すると何が起きるかというと駐車料金駐車料金が発生する
多分頭が出社
通勤なんですけどもう直接駐車場濃縮に来ました
女性の人に聞いたところ本駐車場はどうやら上限金額がな入らなくてまぁいう
テンショナーと何日間で求めていいよというわけでございますえっ
料金アメリカ1税関女学校の授業見た1時間ね300やって2時間出すプラス300円
3時間だと+204時間経つと200やっぱり
4時間を止めると1000円くらい取られると5時間経つと1260が経つと
1400円以後1時間毎100円ということでただいま
本日空月の20室日の15時でございます明日の多分よるかな明日の夜に東海の桜エア
がぼくんちに遊びに行きます
チェックや尋ねたらでて私は車で来るんですけども今回はちょっとドッキリをしようと
思いますてっ
親たちの車を使って多分ね29かなってみんなラーメンを食いに来みたいなことって人
によってこの2シャドーに徹夜の車を駐車させて
ラーメン食いに行くだけなんでもうすぐ駐車してすぐラメ来て帰ってきて1時間くらい
なんで料金的にはだいたい300円くらいだとテツヤは思い込んでいるところを
コッソリ哲也の2車検と僕のこのすごい金額がたまって
2作品を入れ替えてもうせ1月風が止めていない駐車料金がものすごい金額になってい
たら鉄道はどういうリアクションする2社料金ドッキリは今回してみようと思います3
日にバトルドッキリですからねあなたのジョニーなんかせずじゃぁどういう
リアクションするのでしょうか見てみましょう
じゃじゃあ2日御座いましょうかね
霊前には捉えるですね
ブーブーでとりあえず今はねもう昼何で
ブーブー多いとってそれを送ってあげるアーサー iq
here 結構好きなんだよあるパク枚ばそっとぜひ遊んキャッチャーなぁーっ
は97号機 masa
これなんかですかしたらああ
ok れるってやばいどうしたこれだから看護者あ面白くなかった俺が一緒で入れない
ですよ
ガッツじゃこれ以来じゃん
うざい上に来てね可能
勢い余っている
ありがとうございます
ありがとうございますみなさん稲森75ぜっ
ご利用くださいスタッフ今日のないようなんだっていう住所待ってます nod
parker 75と
こちらでございますね
いいですっ
[音楽]
らぁぁ
dare
[音楽]
いやーて2さんおいしかったですねいやいやいやいやラビアドで本当に楽しかったです
が久しぶりだったねなんと1時間300円という激安条件付を
ああああああ
かあさんただいま
帰ってきましたよ僕の旅さあに打って頑張ったら犬も無事ですよ
ネイルまでいってことですけどねまだここから先だねぇ
このパー人超えうえっ
me
あっはぁ
何を除いて前に僕も2させて力日前からえっああれか
上がそうですの3日前から61がじゃないですねよ
です1時間止めただけならにすごい大量のお金で何ドッキリで減って0
ザッハ
いやーあの時のために俺は4日伊賀仕込んでだけだってああいや何かなサブちゃんとる
なあと思った
徹夜と静岡終わるソルチャンシートあんなないよ
[音楽]